[Applause]
families of nicaraguan political
prisoners are calling for the release of
their loved ones
many of whom have been participating in
a hunger strike from behind bars
for more than three weeks they're trying
to call attention to alleged human
rights abuses by nicaraguan security
forces and paramilitary groups
scarlett narvaez says her husband
ernesto is among the prisoners
participating in the hunger strike
she says her husband and several others
have sewn their lips
shut as part of their protest
they made the decision to do a hunger
strike partly as a way to demand their
freedom
because they suffer from constant
physical and psychological mistreatment
nicaragua's president daniel ortega has
denied allegations of torture adding
that human rights observers are welcome
to visit the prisons
the doors are open for you to visit they
say they're being tortured that they're
dying
that they've sewn their lips shut i'd
like to see their lips sewn
they fabricate such things to create a
negative image of nicaragua
in response a team of human rights
observers traveled to el chipote prison
in managua
but were intercepted by security forces
who denied them access
it's a lie that we've been able to prove
the speech from president daniel ortega
was alive from head to toe
where he said the jails were open to
human rights institutions like ours
on october 21st the oas passed a
resolution calling for electoral reforms
in nicaragua and urging the state to
respect human rights
montenegro a defense attorney
representing the families of several
prisoners
says many were hoping the oas resolution
would include a timeline for the release
of political
prisoners
we were expecting the liberation of
political prisoners as a demand
but that's the way things go even the
political prisoners say they feel
they've become a sort of bargaining chip
since the start of the political crisis
in 2018 the nicaraguan government has
been accused
of a long list of human rights
violations
including locking up government critics
and silencing journalists
manuel rapalo al jazeera